[Applaudissements]
des heurts des changes avec des citoyens
pour un candidat à qui on a reproché de
ne pas être suffisamment aller sur le
terrain
d'ici le deuxième tour le 24 avril
l'entourage des manuels macron prévoit
multiplier les événements comme celui-ci
des arts est un peu partout au pays et
pas toujours en territoire ami emmanuel
macron s'est arrêté dans un fief du
rassemblement national marine le pen a
obtenu plus de 40% des voix dans cette
petite ville du nord de la france mais
c'est beaucoup aux électeurs de gauche
que le président sortant tend la main je
suis venu aussi expliquer la réponse
sociale qui a dans le projet que je
porte en particulier pour les
travailleurs comme pour les retraités a
donné ou emmanuel macron a terminé en
troisième position le candidat de gauche
radicale jean luc mélenchon l'a devancé
en obtenant près de 30% des voix le
président cherche à courtiser ses
électeurs lui qui est pourtant critiquée
à gauche pour vouloir faire passer l'âge
de la retraite à 65 ans
devant les électeurs de cette ville
l'une des plus pauvres de france le
candidat promet donc des mesures
économiques et sociales visant à
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat si certains
sont satisfaits des gestes posés par le
gouvernement français au niveau du
pouvoir d'achat
des mesures en france qui nous ont
permis de pour l'instant de deux paliers
au coût de la vie qui augmente et comme
les chèques énergie la colère de
nombreux électeurs est palpable je
trouve ça honteux de débarquer dans une
ville aussi pauvre que demain et faire
le show comme ça c'est ce qui m'a fait
venir à vélo de chez moi parce que j'ai
même plus deuxième voiture a tellement
la vie est de plus en plus cher
on est content tu mens que cherche
justement à canaliser marine le pen du
rassemblement national déjà bien
présente sur le terrain la candidate
d'extrême droite qui travaille depuis
longtemps à adoucir son image vue
rallier les électeurs en mettant
notamment l'accent sur l'inflation et je
compte sur tous les électeurs français
voilà je compte sur leur lucidité je
compte sur leur intelligence je compte
sur leur capacité à prendre conscience
qu'on ne peut pas continuer cinq ans de
plus dans cette situation marine le pen
et emmanuel macron n'ont que deux
semaines pour convaincre les électeurs
orphelins de candidats ou encore ceux
qui sont tentés par l'abstention
dans une course qui s'annonce serré ces
appuis pourrait déterminer le sort de
l'élection ici rappelle bouvier auclair
radio-canada à denain dans le nord de la
france